police said they first got that 9-1-1
call shortly after 10 A.M
the suspected shooter was dead within 15
minutes but the damage was already done
six people including three children lost
their lives we don't yet know a motive
but we do know about the weapons
involved Nashville's police chief said
the suspect was carrying an
assault-style rifle an assault style
pistol and a handgun
law enforcement believes two of the
weapons were obtained legally about
those victims here are their names 60
year old head of school Catherine Coos
custodian Mike Hill substitute teacher
Cynthia Peak both 60s 61 years old and
three nine-year-olds Evelyn Dickhouse
William Kenney and Hallie Scruggs the
daughter of Covenant senior pastor on
covenant's website there's a welcome
message from Coombs who expressed
covenant's Mission helping children
become who God intends them to be